it's Tuesday November 28th the checkin
is brought to you by manscape it's time
to look nice even if you've been naughty
manscape makes sure your grooming is in
check with a fresh launch just in time
for the holiday season their new
performance package
5.0 the lone Mall 5.0 Ultra body trimmer
the weed whacker 2.0 and the ear and
nose hair trimmer that crop suda
aftershave lotion which is tremendous by
the way and their crop preserver ball
deodorant that attracts them like a
[__] listen I love this new [__]
lone mower it's stronger than ever this
[__] thing my white hairs they just
fly off now it's tremendous and the weed
whacker for the
ear Cuts right through everything wax
stami juice your nose hairs thank God
there's no Coke in that knows no more
this thing would cut right through those
cup little cut things like Nino in New
Jack
City anyway the lumm more 5.0 Ultra does
all the heavy lifting with two Next
Generation blad heads it's even
waterproof so you can knock it out of
your shaving routine while you shower
who's better than you manscape get 20%
off in free shipping right now this
holiday season with Co Joe y
manscape.com That's 20% off with free
shipping at manscape.com
use code Joey Joe y listen there's the
perfect grip for Grandpa don't let him
his hairs are longer than Deb he's been
praying at home who's gonna cut my
little knuckle my little staming Roots
here nobody the checkin is also brought
to you by stamps.com listen if you're a
business owner like young Joey and you
have a sleigh to help you with
deliveries this Christmas you need
stamps.com stamps.com is your own
personal post office wherever you are
all you need is a computer and a printer
that's it print your own postage at
discounts up to 84% off of us PS and UPS
rates and stance.com will even let you
know the cheapest and fastest shipping
options to help you save even
more I'm back if you want to save time
as well as money you can even schedule
package pickups through the stamps.com
dashboard it couldn't be any easier so
do me a favor give your business the
gift of stamps.com so your mailing and
shipping is covered this holiday season
I don't care how small or big your
business is stamps.com is the way to go
sign up with promo C Joey for a special
offer that includes a 4-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stance.com Click the microphone at
the top of the page and press in COD
Joey turn up your TVs run for your lives
it's over they didn't put you on this
planet just to give up if Uncle Joey
could do it I can rule the world that's
what you got to be thinking welcome back
to show
what's happened to the L hey buddy you
know me dog Tip Top Magoo on a Monday
the last Monday of the month it is it's
getting crazy we have like four weeks to
the end of until Christmas this year has
had roller skates on it the [__] months
have been on roller skates it's [__]
it's crazy just went through chunks like
just chunks like Mar like you didn't
even know March and April then next you
know you're jumping up and down in May
you're at a Philly game then next then
it's August and you're in North Carolina
and you can't breathe and then it's
October and you're [__] you know
people knocking on your door looking for
K kiky candy or whatever the [__]
they what's going on is that a k cat how
was your Thanksgiving had a great
Thanksgiving man I had a we had it at my
girlfriend's house with her two kids and
that was a lot of fun she didn't she was
getting ready we and then we all went uh
to my aunt's house and the kids met the
rest of my my f side of the family and
it was pretty cool it was cool to see
got
along for the most part it in at daytime
at home there were some it's funny how
like I'm not a parent by any stretch of
the means but I'm I'm sort of in that
that world right now and like they just
they were great all week and they were
great on Thanksgiving but there was a
like a minute in the morning when like
for out of the blue they just like
decided to cause [__] and it's like it's
Thanksgiving morning you're gonna do
this like I was I actually had that
ritten down I was like how are holidays
different for you as like a parent like
because than you want me to tell you
something they mean something now listen
after you [__] 1819
you have no
family your holidays are like [__]
Nomads you know right somebody invites
you over like on the 19th hey you come
you got anywhere to go Christmas Eve nah
come over now you got to hustle up and
shoplift gifts for the family or
whatever if you're gonna give out
handshakes or whatever you know it's
always been something like that ever
since I had the
child it's you know now you get now you
get why you do the things you do you
understand it more she don't believe in
Santa no more so that's good but her
friends still do so listen she ain't
gonna Ratt them out she's pretty cool
with it she figured it out like anybody
any other kid figures it out you know
they figure it out after a while you
open up a closet a [__] a Hot Wheel
track hits you in the head you know you
open it up on Christmas day it's
supposed to be for your cousin now what
what happened there was a mix up here So
eventually kids aren't that [__]
stupid and they figure it the [__] out
heard Amazon's a dick like Amazon will
just leave stuff out it happened it
happens all the time I had a friend it
just happened to the other day somebody
stole it no no they didn't steal it but
they have like kids stuff getting
delivered and it's not put in a box for
some random reason and they just leave
it right
outside yeah like who's that for oh it's
for the little blind kid down the corner
you know you don't know what
so you're happy when the charade is over
it's a sad day because they bought it
right five or six and then they kind of
know you know you ask them what do you
want you make a list you know come on so
and then interesting Mercy's a little
older but like they also have phones so
like they Google it now they can ask
Siri like they're like you're kind of
screwed you're kind of screwed got in
this [__] house so you yes you do no
I don't what do you mean you don't I
live by the [__] book I take the
phones out of the rooms where I talk now
that's why sometimes I don't even get
your calls because I charge phones in a
room where I'm not at no more no more
chitchat in front of the [__] phones
you know what I'm saying I put on
[__] at night even TVs have
microphones now everything everything
everything it's a [__] nightmare and
these guys that go home and bang out
[__] masturbation online you're
sitting there they got your face they're
just saving it they'll sell that to
Scientology next thing you know you're
[__] in a in a band with Travolta
singing Christmas songs and Scientology
for a bunch of [__] people so nah
that's why I don't like that none that
perverted stuff none of that there's a
situation going on here close to home
about a place and they had some
problems and a lot of people I know went
in there and you know
now you got to wait to see who knocks on
your [__]
door and that's why it's better if you
know they got it's a different world
today cameras have changed especially if
you lived when there weren't No
cameras you know like just you still
take things for granted every movement
you make you know from the time you
leave your [__] garage in the morning
you got to assume every movement you
make is that's why I don't understand
how they like years from now they
probably have them already a satellite
that's up
there and when they have a cop chase
it's taping all day and when they have a
murder occurs or something all they got
to do is go to the satellite and there
you are running out of the house with
[__] you know a bag of [__] you stole
and a bloody knife they got you they got
you there and then like what about like
ring like because like I think ring owns
all that
footage I like think about all like the
video doorbells now they have cameras
they had us put
cameras in the suburbs and like I guess
everywhere but it's just pretty crazy
like they could have access the
government could get access to that if
they wanted to dog in my hometown where
I grew up in North Bergen you can't piss
on the street if a a cop will be there
in eight
minutes you litter a cop will be there
in eight minutes you know this town
where I live they have cameras
everywhere
they have Cam it's a big kid town
There's softball fields everywhere
there's Parks everywhere you know they
got cameras everywhere and I feel better
you know because you can't have no
[__] guys walking around with a rainy
jacket with a Long Jacket giving out
candy down here they get spotted right
away but you know it sucks for other
reasons let's say you want to take your
girlfriend to the park and throw her a
little salami sandwich you know there's
a camera now that you know if you want
to smoke a number there's a camera
now so there's a lot of uh there's a lot
of negative you know New York City is
one big
camera oh yeah absolutely New York's
crazy New York City it's one big camera
you got to assume you're getting taped
from eight different [__]
locations especially going into this
this holiday season now with the tree
and all the tourists that fly back here
and [__] like that it's uh it's it's
it's
surreal it's
surreal and and they like they I I don't
do a lot of conspiracy theories but like
they're doing it in China right now they
have like cameras and they like that's
how you pay for things that's how you
get into buildings is they scan your
face and it's it's it's not even just
like a hidden camera it's like right in
your face and they have like the a
social credit score based on like how
you behave lets you do certain things
and it's all like facial they have they
building cities it's crazy I'm telling
you it's G Vegas is going to be soon
like that all the money there you know I
know for years I won't even I I told you
before I won't bang when out in the room
in
Vegas they got cameras I ain't bringing
nobody up there that's [__] weird
they got cameras you got to assume you
know you have to assume now do you I
don't know what it is about me I can't
if you're staying at a nice place I
can't think that they're doing bad
things in hotel rooms like do you did
you ever like do stuff like that like
like not have the comforter down CU
that's like they say they don't watch
that [__] and like you're saying they
have cameras in the
rooms do you think they do that a lot
well they don't listen man they're gonna
cut Corners especially now you go into a
room during covid you better check
everything there's an ashtray under your
bed with cracking it in the pipe you
know they don't have look what's going
on in Vegas didn't they have didn't they
have a maid problem in Vegas just like
Union yeah they went on strike I think
so you have to assume again that
whatever Hotel you're going into after
Co listen any hotel you go into now
doesn't have the same ameni it had
before covid when you go on the website
they're still on there but when you get
there and you go where's the bar they're
like we haven't had a bar since after
Co where's the restaurant that used to
be in here you know when you go on the
Road those little they're not holiday
inss it's another chain you got those
little restaurants in there the food's
not great but they do they do makes egg
sunny side up for breakfast it's not
like powdered eggs and you know the
wheat toast so I used to always get the
breakfast there lunch is not you know
it's like a roast beef sandwich they
have like cream of onion soup or
something not for me but all those
places somebody was telling me they're
done yeah they don't have any any of the
those things and then I mean and never
did it I I never liked people coming
into my hotel room but most places if
you're there for less than I think it's
like four or five days they don't clean
your room unless you ask for it I went
when I drove to Nashville this year on
the way back we stopped in Pennsylvania
one night and we could not find the
hotel room we were like four hours away
we could not find the hotel room we had
already been in the car 11 hours and we
could we just wiped on the way there
it's easier than the way back right oh
finally found the hotel and it was
packed soon as you went in this place
stunk my wife came out and she goes
listen it's the only hotel room in town
and they don't have an elevator and
we're like on the third
floor it was like walking two foot wall
Fields over there soon as you walked on
the room it smelt like you walked into
the plaza in Vegas cigarettes you know
the next my wife goes I'm going down to
get breakfast I
wouldn't
she's like no let's go have the coffee
she went and got the coffee she threw
everything out when she got to the room
it was just everything was
unedible but the hotel we stayed at in
Tennessee I would move into that
place oh yeah what did they have it was
just a great hotel Holiday and express
owned by Southern women [__] they had
a great breakfast they had a great
dinner spread at night I mean listen
you're not going to find stuff pork shop
with mozzarel you know it's [__]
Tennessee but they tried but the
breakfast was surreal every morning the
breakfast was on point and there was a
couple breakfast spots and I kept saying
let's just stay here because I hate
leaving you know from over the years of
Comedy you gotta leave some hotels to
get what [__] potato chips and a soda
right when I started comedy there wasn't
no [__] like there is now Lee where you
go to a hotel room and you're like ah
you know
let me and get ham and eggs and [__]
that was Dick nobody gave you a free
[__]
breakfast nobody and I've got tons of
stories where you got to wake up in the
morning they got free coffee but you're
a comic you wake up at 11: the coffee is
like [__] shoe leather and now you
have to leave the hotel to go get
something to eat and that's a nightmare
in itself especially if you don't have a
car especially if you drove with the
headliner or you took a bus up there or
something to that effect
and like what if you didn't cuz I think
about that a lot
is like you like if you're if you are
like surviving on Comedy money at like a
$100 a
show you probably can't eat out that
much like you couldn't order delivery
like you could but like if you're making
50 100 bucks a
show how are you supposed to eat out for
a week Orek go 7-Eleven and they got
frozen pizzas and TV dinners and Frozen
chickens yeah that's the life of a
comedian TV diners those
burritos two of those [__] with
a Coke and a bag of Cheetos
chili it ain't
healthy but you ate right
really hard to think the [__] I ate when
I was flat broke just to maintain just
to do comedy and I knew it was bad for
me but I didn't give a [__] you know
those frozen burritos listen you take
those frozen burritos back to your room
you just don't eat them out of the
baggie you put some [__] past Picante
on there a little bit of cheese maybe
some jalapenos you dope them up a little
bit and they're not that bad in the
hotel room when you you know when you
have 20 bucks left and one joint and you
know you got to drive two
hours that [__] all you know you you
figure out you balance out what's
important and it's so weird and then
when you do a good meal you appreciate
it so [__] much on the road like
there's a guy I'll never forget because
the opening night Thursday night after
the show he'd always take the comedians
only to
dinner that's nice the place where he
was taking you was already
closed wow you had the restaurant to
yourself the they knew about it the
family it was up in
Milwaukee and that you know you I
thought about it years
later first off he he took you to a
restaurant
Thursday Saturday he cooked for
you at the club barbecue style and
Saturday morning he took you to
breakfast
wow the guy tried the guy
really that's really nice like but and
just like for people listening I think
and I'm not complaining at all but at
most like people like uh Club will order
out for you like that's not that's not
usual thing to be that involved I
think it was that you know and now I see
years later where the value was in it
you know like you know I know you guys
been traveling you're on a bus you're
here you're there you're eing [__] just
places it wasn't dantas it wasn't uh but
it was like a Milwaukee it was like a
Wisconsin restaurant they had a lot of
stews and everything was thick and thick
Breads and [__] it was [__]
phenomenal
and I went there twice and both times
Thursday night let's go we're going over
to this restaurant so now thinking back
on it it's pretty nice and for anybody
who has a comedy club or whatever try
that you know if you're a Booker and
you're doing a one nighter and people
coming in from out of town the first
night of the show take them somewhere
nice you know not Hey listen it doesn't
have to be a $3,000 dinner but just the
effort es take us back to your mom's
house
you know I'll eat some home
cooking if your mom if your mom makes
lasagna tray that goes a long way and
she gives you a piece to go home with
you're starving comic are you [__]
kidding
me so these are the things you learn as
you uh go along how was your week last
week comedy wise comedy wise I had a
great week last week I I did five spots
uh two were shows and three were open
mics and
I I had a cool week because I I I was
kind of nervous about it I I think I've
told you I didn't really do well in
front of Bookers before
and I decided to release a clip that I
was really nervous about and so I didn't
want to do most of those jokes at these
shows with the Bookers because I was
hope you know people came out I didn't
want them to think if I have 10 minutes
they've seen seven of it already um and
so I did like completely different sets
than I normally
do and they both went great and so I'm
going to hopefully get to do more shows
with each with each group well
congratulations as far as the [__]
Booker's
concerned listen man you're G to go up
in front of a lot of Bookers in your
day you know every Club has a [__]
Booker and then when you get to a
certain level you got Bookers from TV
shows and comedy companies and and all
these people coming to watch
you and uh I think the biggest showcase
I ever had was at the 9-year Mark which
was Mitsy Shore yeah holy [__] and you
know it's like anything else man when
you're there you see the work you put in
you know you know what I'm saying so at
that
time remember I used to tell you that I
used to call clubs I was just a [__]
salesman and I go listen I like to come
to your club and do a guess that this is
who referred me but if I go there on
Saturday night I want to make sure on
Sunday night I want to make sure the
booker is gonna be there oh he'll be
here so all those years of having the
booker there prepared me for
that I'm I'm I'm sure you've told it a
couple of times but I I honestly just
don't remember and I'd love to hear it
can like can you quickly tell like
you're showcasing for mity story
between you and me I don't [__] even
remember it
anymore it was you
know at that time I had already done
like the year before the year before
that I had done the Seattle comedy
competition okay so five nights in a row
you gotta go up Seven Nights the first
week you're going up in front of judges
you know and then the second week again
it's seven you know so that at the end
of the [__] month you go up and front
of 30 [__]
judges and there's other Bookers there
you know from the area Seattle area
there's other Bookers from Comedy Club
chains you know and you're going up in
front of them me I prefer when you come
up to me after my set and go hey I work
for the funny
bones I book six clubs I just saw you
destroyed I'd like to get your info I
hate if you come up to me before that
you know right but naturally when you do
those things you have to assume there's
people there in the audience you know I
just spoke to a writer last week who I'm
going to work with for the book you know
to expand it and when he wrote back did
I send you a copy of the letter no he
sent me like a letter saying this is why
I think I should work with you and part
of that letter was him coming to The
Comedy Store for like two or three years
to watch Comedy on Tuesday nights wow
and he said how he watched me grow blah
blah blah blah blah but we already had a
relationship by Me by him coming did I
know he was ever in the audience did I
know that high-powered writers like that
were in the audience at The Comedy Store
no I would have [__] my pants if
somebody would have came up to me and
said you're going up in front of six
writers from CBS or NBC see so you see
what happens like you don't even know
and you have a good set that's why
people always tell you just to be
yourself that that and and it sounds so
cliche and so
cornboy but it's [__]
true you know if you see that Booker in
the room don't act up like
you act like you usually act go up to
the girl give her a kiss hey what's
going on here any of my [__] call
that he's watching everything you have
to assume they're watching every move
from the minute you walk in that
showroom to check in you know whatever
who's talking to you your
manager and then you go up there and you
deliver the [__] Goods but the most
important thing is to be yourself like
I've seen great comics showcased with
great things they had a set that that
person came to see right that person
came to you and said hey last Thursday
night I saw you at the Improv and you
were fantastic called the Laugh Factory
you think you could do that next
Thursday night I'm going to bring
everybody from the tonight's show out to
see
you you know what like a guy like me an
idiot like me would show up with a whole
different 10
minutes I knew that's what you gonna say
oh my god really yeah an idiot like me
would show up with new 10 to show you
that I'm [__] Johnny extraordinary
it all depended on what part of my
career you caught me
at right now I know that if you saw me
on a Thursday last week I'm going to go
on a piece of paper somewhere where I
wrote like a couple
anchors I didn't write my set out I
wrote a couple anchors just to move them
around I'm at The Comedy Store I'm at
The Improv you
know and that's what I'm going to do but
somebody like me the old me would have
gone with a whole new tech
minutes [__] see like that I just
hearing that request all I could think
about was do I have to do it word for
word what if I had a good interaction
with somebody at the Improv but then
this week I don't have that interaction
and now it looks like I
bombed no just just go oh my God i' to
work it around the same material and if
you see an opening take the opening if
not stick to your material this is NBC
this is the tonight's show
or this is an HBO special this is Jimmy
Kimmel this is anybody you know at the
end of the day it's all the same [__]
it's how you control your nerves it's
your
breathing you know what I always like to
do is try to hit them hard heavy so you
get the confidence
going if you go out there with a dragged
out long one minute joke you don't
really know where you stand you come out
[__] taking swings you're either
going to die or you you're going to come
out extra hype and then you're just
sailing from there it's only 10 minutes
I'm trying to do 35 minutes in 10
minutes I Don't Want You to Breathe I'm
gonna keep punching in the
stomach like a like one of those Rock
them sck them [__] robot
so so i' rather give you that advice
than the Mitsy sh thing how's that okay
I love that I love and you know what we
didn't I don't know if you want to go
back there but we didn't even talk about
your Thanksgiving how was your
Thanksgiving my Thanksgiving was very
kumy Kuma you know what I'm saying I uh
woke up nice and early I [__] worked
out I went to work with my buddy we did
a nice 45 minute workout I came home I
put some ice on my ankle you know and
then about I watched there was a
honeymoon
uh [__] afternoon like a couple
episodes like uh from Marathon a
marathon from 11: to 3 nice at 3 we went
over there and with the Pumas thank
goddamn vus you know that she's a great
[__] cook
Jody she put together a [__] turkey
she made my favorite because she knows I
like stove stop toughing I don't want to
eat none of your [__] International
stuffing with roots and beets I don't
want to taste it the pilgrims didn't
have any of that they had stoed top all
right so she made [__] like waffles
out of Stove Top O she put them the
waffle machine [__] genius you put
the white meat on top of that you throw
a hand scoop of mashed potatoes on top
of that and some a little bit of
cranberry sauce and some maluia
gravy I had one of them I was done was
it like all crispy yes the stuffing that
sounds really [__] good telling you
she hit it out of the [__] Park Jody
Puma the gravy melted it through the
layers and I don't even like gravy me
either what's that I don't like it
either yeah but you got to throw the
gravy on
there [__] throw the gravy on there it
was perfect and then uh we watched the
first game I forgot who the [__] it was
and then we went to the muros around the
corner for the late night [__]
AAR and they busted out desserts they
had like maybe they had more [__]
desserts than what's that ice cream
store that has all the flavors Bas
Robins they got 200 flavors they beat
them that night they had everything
moose Goose [__] Jello popsicles they
had everything [__] Ben and Jerry's
this that Briar couple uh a couple of
apple pies I tell you what I didn't eat
this year what's that pumpkin
pie what made you stay away from it I
didn't I I I I forgot all about it it
was there and I always said I'll get
back to it later I I never liked any pie
I I like you know I like pean pie that's
pretty good I have recently
had they had an Oreo cake at uh my
aunt's house did you tear that up I did
have a piece of it all right so you
enjoyed it was it was it was really but
what did you have instead of pumpkin
pie I probably broke down at the muros
cuz the Edibles kicked in and I had a a
[__] uh an apple pie o I do like I do
like apple crisp so that sounds like
that was oh [__] they're cousins Apple
Chris Apple pumpkin whatever the [__]
they're all cousins with a scoop of
Bri's vanilla ice cream old school with
the little chocolate
[__] uh spots in it you know you said
something what's up with the little
spots in it okay vanilla bean spots in
it it's brilliant I have haven't had it
in 20 years but when I saw it I said I
got to attack this and it's [__]
brilliant that was the only thing I ate
that was the only dessert I
ate you said something last week that I
I was thinking about this week and you
you were talking about like people
messing up mashed potatoes and I was
thinking about that you and Terry had a
story that didn't you like stop being
friends completely with someone I got
mad at it I got mad for I didn't talk to
it for about months because of the
mashed
potatoes listen man there's some things
I eat once you've had great mashed
potatoes it's tough to go back to shitty
mashed potatoes especially when you're a
fat [__] like we are okay there's
something about the essence of mashed
potatoes dish especially when like
they're
whipped mashed potatoes if you're eating
mashed potatoes and you're trying to be
healthy go shoot yourself right now
nobody Eats mashed potatoes who wants to
be [__] healthy it's a special
goddamn treat so do me a favor when we
have it throw down don't be shy with
that Irish butter you know what I'm
saying don't be shy with that pepper
throw some red onions in that [__] you
ever have [__] no you ever have uh
mashed potatoes with the Peels and red
onions in that [__] Le I've
never had red onions in it cooked or not
cooked I mean they're heated up with the
potatoes so okay so like like like sa a
little
this [__] used to make them in
Bow to Colorado and make me lose my mind
I would eat them just to that's the only
mashed potato I would just eat the
mashed potato and Cubans make something
that's very good I never had it again
after my mother died it's called
Malanga what is that m a l a n GA it's
like a [__] potato it's long but it's
brown it's it's wild but it's [__]
delicious with butter
salt and pepper you know oh [__]
delicious and that's where I love I like
potatoes and I like whatever the [__] I
told you I forget the Malanga Malanga so
but what did your friend do that made
you so
upset the friend that invited me over on
the on this most sacred day of mashed
potatoes listen you want to [__] mashed
potatoes up in July I ain't gonna get
mad at you okay you [__] them up in
September I ain't gonna get mad at you
but on the national day of potatoes
which is
Thanksgiving you better come correct you
got to show up with both guns and one in
your [__] ankle okay especially when
it comes to mashed [__] potatoes
so I went over there and they were like
[__] bed potatoes the whole dinner
was disaster it was [__] a TR dunan a
turkey with a a duck in it I don't want
to take that if you want to do that make
two [__] turkeys give us an option
why you feed me this cuz you think it's
good I don't think it's good everything
was nasty but nothing insulted me more
was the mashed potatoes I took it to
heart I took it to heart that I went
home and just passed out angry and my
wife woke me up at two o'clock in the
morning she made me a Thanksgiving
dinner because she knew how
important you get up all year you pay
taxes you do the best you can the least
am man could ask for is mashed potatoes
on [__]
Thanksgiving yeah but to do it at like 2
in the morning is that is that when you
were you married yet at that
point no we were getting close though
yeah I was gonna say that's [__] I
was like I was [__] upset L like man
how the [__] you gonna [__] up mashed
potatoes on
Thanksgiving they were and well I'm not
exaggerating they weren't even the
ballpark Le she got him out of a box
like those box ones that right there I
got to I got to put you on I got 86 you
for 90day
mandatory and what does that 86 entail
like no communication nothing I don't
want to know nothing you [__] up I'm
not even gonna tell you why you [__]
up I'm not gonna say nothing to you I'm
just I'm not picking up the [__]
phone don't call me no more for 90
days how many people just don't call
back
they don't 90 days like I think I think
he doesn't want to talk to me anymore
why I talk to her for 180 days I put her
in a real pay on mind list that's how
insulted I was about the [__] mashed
potatoes but why don't you tell people
like what their
sentences I don't know what their
sentences it's their sentences I don't
know I don't know how I feel in the
morning after you try to [__] poison
me on thanks you know like you're not
going to sit there and tell me I didn't
have the right here if this was another
country I could have I could press
charges for making B mashed potatoes on
Thanksgiving thank God I'm not a [__]
Crim stopper I have no problem with your
I just I just think it's funny to think
about like just you just you went to
Thanksgiving and then didn't call her
for 10 months or answer her calls it was
November 20 whatever and I didn't talk
to till like April or May she finally
called me one day she's like what's your
problem you won't pick up your phone I
said something like the first time I I
go [__] Lear how to make mashed
potatoes I just hung up on
it and then she called the friend she
goes what is he talking
about oh my God you know poison me but
you didn't listen by giv tried to poison
you it it it broke me down
emotionally and [__] spiritually and
physically because I I trust you you
she's first off I know her very well she
always throws down a great meal you know
I know her from Texas I was friends with
her back in
Houston but I think a boyfriend and he
was a half a [__] you know he had
light shoes like post Malone you know
you don't like post Malone I didn't say
I didn't like post Malone I just said he
always tips to like a burglar like he
walks real late like you know okay a
burglar a couple things he's just
lighting the shoes you know what I'm
saying I understand so so she had a
boyfriend like that right away you got
to put words in my mouth then the next
day the paparazzi picked it up Uncle Joy
don't like post Malone I like post
Malone music I was listening to him a
couple days ago I mean I'm not gonna you
know not put him on over lead Zeppelin
but if I'm sing there and I'm smoking a
couple [__] numbers not nothing wrong
with post Malone no I I just I didn't
picture you as a huge post Malone fan no
I didn't say did I say I would would I
say when I blow the nickel to go [__]
alone and jump up and down a lot of
other people that are tight [__] the
life like it it sounded like that's what
you wanted for Christmas no no
no no
just just because I like music don't
mean I want to hang out with you and
[__] jump up and
down you know is there any concert that
you'd go to right now is it like was
there any because I can't imagine going
anywhere if I go to a concert first of
all right now not today but it has to be
a small venue
anymore I'm old school I rather go to
those American Express concerts where
you get the small venue and you know I
didn't do I didn't go see Chris Cornell
here in the city or anything but when I
lived in La I got to see guns and roses
with Dean and Bill Burr at the [__]
Palladium and that's like you know 2,000
seats
it's a little bit more personal you know
but these big Forum things I don't want
to get tickets I got to walk two miles
you look at my Weight Watches I walk
22,000 steps I I don't need that to to
hear the same music I've been listening
to for 40 [__]
years would you pay more to go to a
smaller venue
absolutely interesting it's really
interesting you said that to me was
talking to a a music guy today and we
were talking about Pink Floyd okay and
he was saying
that where they messed up with music
years ago because they didn't know was
that they should have taped all their
concerts people really should have
really taped high quality all their
concerts it would have taken a big chunk
out of their income but what they didn't
know that today you could sell that
experience
I could get you into a hotel and that's
what he was saying he goes think of what
people pay for the soup bowl
experience it's an experience he goes I
don't know what the concerts are like
today but from listening to I mean I'm
older than this guy and we were talking
he goes my dad used to tell me these
[__] stories and yeah and I go
they're all true all those lead lead
Zeppelin shows in the city Rolling Stone
tours they were all [__] insane you
know but he was like you could sell like
right now if they would have shot Pink
Floyd The
Wall and really taped it well you could
have took a theat of broken in half and
he goes you could sell those seats for
$155,000 and people will pay it because
it's an experience you know now you got
to play it back with the modern
speakers and the new technology you have
to edit it and clean it up well you know
digitally
remastered but uh I'm sure I'm sure
they're all doing it
now they have to I'm sure that you
know it's an experience it's a festival
it's something that I can connect with
my kid
with so if they asked me for 15 grand I
don't I don't know if I got the 15 grand
for that
but it's a
thought that if my daughter likes leg
Zeppelin and I had gone to see Leed
Zeppelin I wasn't that fortunate I could
take my daughter to go see that same
concert that's mindblowing or a [__]
baseball game yeah oh my God yeah
baseball game that I went to where you
know who cares name of Boston Red Sox he
hit two home runs that game and you
happen to get 8 tickets and the people
next to you bought you beers all
afternoon and they were nice they were
from [__] Woodford and you were from
Medford and everybody talked about salty
you know and it was a [__]
experience for people to see that they
would [__] their
pants what it was like when you went to
a baseball game and you know some
[__] snuck in a bucket of
Kentucky Fried Chicken and that whole
two sections was eating Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you're like man I came to
this game having a bad day and just
being here it's 80 degrees a bird [__]
on me you know I was at Shay stadium and
a bird [__] on me but just the fact that
you could share those experiences with
your child with your father with your
mother maybe your mother wanted to go
see Barbara strian in New York City when
she was going to college there but the
tickets were too expensive we could
relive that you know pick her up in a
limo take her to a thing you know and
forget about what AI is going to do
because they can actually have Barber
strian there greeting you yeah I was
going to say VR I like I I'm sorry you
know I'm not no no no but no AI is not
probably not wrong they can create
people like they could make concerts
that didn't have and happen like they
they could AI is definitely gonna pay
play a part in it it's
uh that would be interesting all CU we
like you've talked about that for a
while with comedy with like like
recording the sets up to a special to
see like the like how like the set was
built I like all that stuff too but also
like uh these festivals that Bert puts
on yeah oh yeah experience brother tape
those tape those from underneath looking
okay and you tape those and 30 years
from now you could go see Burke ker you
go see Dave Chappelle at the
Garden but hold on one second I got to
break because I got to talk to these
people about popcorn the [__] listen I
hate popcorn but this popcorn is g to
put you over the [__] top I'll be
right back guys like I told you in the
podcast listen their new popcorn I love
this company Kudo popcorn if you're
trying to eat less garbage especially
this holiday season you got to try Kudo
popcorn it tastes a m listen tremendous
it has 10 grams of whey protein isolate
in every bag MMA athletes like Michael
Chandler Robie Lola and Dana White love
it and for a good reason whey protein
helps boost muscle mass so whether
you're getting ready for a big fight or
just hitting the gym after work it's
going to help you reach your goals
listen I love the garlic parmesan I love
the white cheddar and I love the salty
sweet kettle corn I got a box in the
mail one day I thought it was like shoes
or something I open it up it's like 10
bags of popcorn I opened one up just to
eat one to try it as a snack do I ate
like three bags right off the bat they
were tremendous and now I had a midnight
snack which you know Uncle Joey I like
to hit the pipe from time to time and
you don't want to be eating garbage this
is the way to go Kudo is glutenfree
preservative free 100% whole grain keto
friendly and only has 70 calories per
cup it's even made right here in the USA
do me a favor you'll be amazed how Kudo
popcorn has somehow made your favorite
healthy smack even tastier and healthier
for a limited time our listeners get
25% off that's 25% off when you use code
Joey at Kudos snacks.com that's 25% off
with code Joey at Kudo KU d snacks.com
save some money support the official
protein popcorn of the UFC and get pop
the popcorn is great guys I wouldn't uh
lie to you about this this white cheddar
is off the hook and again the garlic
parmesan and they had one of the flavor
that drove me crazy but give it a shot
look it up do what you need to do it's
Tuesday baby the 28th get your life
together back to the podcast now we're
back anyway we would talk that's the
[__] future I know for a fact I heard
something that they're thinking of
touring like you know I think it's
Biggie and
Tupac yeah I'm sure there are and and
because I was thinking about what like
what you were talking about and it
clicked that like you're talking about
like not just the performance but like
everything around it did you I it's way
too long to watch the whole thing but
they did a whole documentary on
Woodstock yeah they have all that
footage like that would be one I think
to go to because like when when you're
talking about what you're talking about
I think you kind of have to if you want
that you kind of have to start
interviewing people there don't you and
like to like like Le calm down on the
reefer it's got you planed I'm not
interviewing [__] nobody I know
you're not interviewing anybody but
you're talking it would just
be let's say Woodstock would be a great
idea to see what additional footage they
have you'd have to go through whoever
owns the footage you know it's a process
but if there's money
involved this could be a [__] great
idea and I mean you go to Woodstock
you're wearing a [__] shirt from the
60s you ain't show for a week you got
flipflops on you got an ingrown toenail
you're going all out the girl you're
taking got syphilis maybe you get her a
shot to get the syphilis from the
jungles I don't know I don't [__]
know but it's just going and seeing the
music and the
smells you know if somebody could
recreate the smells the mud I don't
[__] know Lee I just know
that if there was a highlevel Pink Floyd
wall it's on it's on
YouTube look it up Pink Floyd The Wall
February
20th
1980 it's the opening night it's on
there it's just not taped like you would
take it's a it's a whatever a bootleg
right you you you want high quality like
they did it on purpose it looks and
sounds great I want to see the sweat on
his face so at one time of the
experience I could just throw a Mist in
the air like they do on that Disney show
the It's a Small World After All where
you sit in the [__] chair and they
take you all around the world and when
you're going through India they throw
sand at you and then you know it's
[__] tremendous you get married they
throw rice at you you want to have the
sweat come at you you want to miss
people with people sweat yeah not with
the real sweat but just a little mist of
[__] warm water because you're taken
in by the experience you're not even
going to feel the this till Midway I
mean that's the whole thing I mean like
I said you're paying 15 grand 20 grand
for this and 10 for your kid they can't
give you they got they're not g to send
you sell you a
$100,000 project with $10 shoes on right
for me to charge you that [__] dough
I gotta impress the [__] out of you I
gotta make you leave there and go dog I
do it again I'm taking a second mortgage
on of my house I'm taking my mother and
father yeah like if you if you could
recreate like an entire experience four
hours five
hours warm-ups walking through the
[__] thing you know and I'm not
talking about VR I'm talking about
surround sound all around screens all
around I mean this is Big Money Lee this
isn't two podcast dudes are gonna do
this no I think this might be technology
that doesn't exist yet too I like like
way future you know me dog I'm in the
future I'm taking these Edibles I'm
thinking about
things I never would have thought that
would be what you would think about hi
you know when my friend told me today I
was like wow that is something that
would change entertainment for [__]
ever because if if I could take a
baseball game if I could take game five
of Cincinnati against
Boston and I don't know I don't know how
I would present it I don't know if I I
would go to
Fenway yeah pay the 15 grand along with
a lot of other people I don't know how
to do it but just to have that on the
field to watch that exact game
with Colton Fisk and all
that I would I think I'd have a nervous
breakdown because it would take me back
to being in that bedroom on my mother's
bed watching it [__] with crosses all
over me and I'm like Cincinnati has to
win or I'm gonna [__] die in this
house they just gonna sacrifice me you
know so how old were
you I was about maybe 10 or 11 or 12 but
I just became a Cincinnati Red fan when
I was a kid did they lost to Oakland to
somebody something happened and I really
liked them and then I just saw I saw him
lose and I then I saw him win a World
Series against one of the best teams I
ever saw the Boston Red Sox at that time
with you know they had the [__] one
of the best teams ever they just
couldn't win a World Series but that was
a battle and even to show people like I
would pay 20 grand to see all six
games [__] like don't even take me
home 18 hours in a [__] capsule with
20 other sweaty fat dudes with [__]
you know with [__] blankets on their
faces from the tears rolling down
because that's
how you know that's what this game would
mean to
you now would you and I don't it's not
necessarily better but like what if you
could have like if you could plan out I
have an hour and I want to be at these
10 plays or like 20 like if like you
could just go to see like every cool
sports moment that you ever wanted to
see it's tremendous like just see that
moment that would be crazy so I think I
know that going ahead with the
technology that I know hasn't been made
[Laughter]
yet you know I'm sorry about that but
it's you just see it coming so you know
if you think about it listen if I think
about a technology me being an idiot I
can't imagine what the smart people are
really thinking about right
now I you just gave someone an idea you
could have I just went to a doctor's
visit maybe a month ago and we were
talking about he goes you got a couple
options left for your left knee but
eventually it's going to have to be
redone and he goes I know you're a
little hesitant he goes but let me tell
you something that whole situation has
changed he goes it's changed so much
that they put the painkiller in your
kneecap now they just insert painkiller
into your kneecap kneecap and it
releases it when you need it he was
telling me all this [__] it's a vacuum
thing now you know not that I'm gonna do
it I'm not saying I'm GNA do it but he
was telling me how much the Technology's
changed since I did my right
knee so you always have to think that
everything's moving I mean talked I've
spoken to you I've spoken to Mike and
every once in a while you guys hit me
with an app and I'm like oh my God
that's a great [__]
idea your own radio station you know
your own this your own that you you know
how many times people sit there I watch
the [__] NFL game and I turn off the
volume yeah okay but are you telling me
you could do better than these guys
let's do it step up to the pump
[__] there's an app called you
know take me to the Ball Game
and [__] uh you're there whether it's
soccer basketball NFL football or uh
whatever the [__] left baseball pro
you could call your own [__] games
and take donations or charge a monthly
[__] fee give them the first two
weeks for free and if they don't sign a
waiver then after two weeks you charge
whatever $9.95 I mean guys that's that's
there
already that's some some somebody's
already doing that so any idea you may
have at the house that you want to be
creative about and you're like well I
don't know I I always wanted to be an
announcer at a strip club I guarantee
there's an app right now that there's
girls on the screen somewhere in
Bulgaria and there you are coming up to
the stage it's Brandy let's give it up
for I I don't I don't even know anything
about that world but I you have to
assume these
things
you have to just go yeah this has to
exist because I'm an idiot and I thought
about
it it does seem like that's how things
are getting made now but there like
there's robots that will cook your food
now I can't imagine what's gonna happen
with podcasting in two years you're just
gonna sign up for a [__] Apple thing
and they're gonna do all this they're
gonna do a thousand things you could
just do it at the house they're going to
do a thousand things you know you can't
imagine what's going to happen not that
I'm going to be any good at it you know
I don't know nothing about that [__] but
this is what's going on every day in our
world right
now it's you have to accept
it oh there's there's a constant CH see
now I know the HBL are hitting me oh why
is that they just because I'm talking
[__] I'm talking gibberish here now you
know what I'm
saying I love it believe had two good
picks this weekend I only put two Pi you
won both of them yeah I had Denver
because I always love Denver giv a small
amount at home on a
Sunday and then I took the under in
Baltimore last night I just took a
chance I said let me use the $27 I won
on the first game you know that was
interesting you got both I got both but
it's
it's it's uh it's really
interesting I I sit around I do a bunch
of things I mean the last two weeks have
been [__] brutal with this
ankle but uh listen I'm back it hurts
still but it yeah man it had you know I
gotta ice it three times a day I gota I
I've been looking at how many steps I
take I think if I walk over
4,000 that's to the 12's
up [__] and it's been like two weeks now
will be uh two two weeks on
Thursday
[__]
so and like I'm lifting
weights I'm doing situps in my fat tummy
I'm on the [__] bike and uh I'm
sleeping I'm sleeping great as a matter
of fact I sleep like a [__] baby
now she's getting bigger and now we're
just uh November 27th we don't stop this
[__] party till Christmas Eve it's
over you know oh yeah and I was go ahead
I'm sorry I was when you were talking
about sports I wanted to talk to you
about Tommy
DeVito that the Giants quarterback and
see what you thought did you have you
heard about him I heard he was a
bartender in Hoboken I know he lived at
home with his mother or something like
that yeah know he's won two games with
the
Giants he's won I think he's won at
least two games
and you know like this week I tried to
watch I think you and I were on the
phone for about a minute while game was
on it was0 and we were like what was the
over under them we're like 16 it was
awful I didn't watch the game I'm happy
they won the Giants I'm happy for D Vito
but if you know anything about me I'm
happy for that [__] that's like
a rocky story he's living at his
mother's house she's making pasta for
him and he's bartending at a [__] bar
in Hoboken and
from the Giants let me read the quote
because I when I saw this it's all I was
you all was all I could think about he
said it was a no-brainer for me I don't
have to worry about laundry what I'm
eating for dinner chicken cutlets and
all that is waiting for me when I get
there my mom still makes my bed
everything is handled for
me and I just thought about like you
that's that's like your dream Andy's the
Giant's
quarterback it's a Rags the richest
story because if he wins two more games
somebody's going to pick him up next
year right and it may be the Giants
because he's a HomeTown [__] you know
he's a jersey boy so listen he gets all
my [__] respect in the world I'm
happy even if he doesn't win another
game dog he was
bartending he won two NFL
games he's working with something
there's something there somebody has to
pick him up and work with him but the
balls in the heart are there
so you know I mean the Giants weren't
the best team in the world it's not like
he he fell into the Dallas Cowboys or
you know the Kansas City Chiefs or
something like that a position he fell
into a hard [__] job you know so I
give him all the credit in the world he
lost a game or two and then his
confidence started to pick up which is
acceptable and now he's got two W's he
needs two more and some they'll reach
out next year and go listen come on over
here for you
know and you never know what this kid
could do what if the kid wins a Super
Bowl in two
years right I
mean if the Giants don't take him next
year what if this kid goes somewhere and
wins a [__] Super Bowl how great
would that be you know that's why I get
up and go you see guys nothing happens
on the couch
[__] I mean even if they had a
Super Bowl in New York or New Jersey
again and he was the quarterback for the
Giants even if they lost bro that that's
just s to go from
bartending to a [__] stage like the
Super Bowl that's [__] amazing where
I come from you know so I'm happy for
all that type of [__] I I can't tell you
that I sit by the TV and watch the game
because they're brutal I was doing
something you know on the Lord's day I
was moving around this Sunday I've been
busy
man yeah you seem like it really [__]
busy for what's been going on in the
world you follow me I got uh I picked up
a voice over for a a kid show a
Nickelodeon show nice I picked up
another audition for a animated pilot I
picked up another voiceover I picked up
a regular audition for one of my
favorite
shows uh I hope it goes you know it's
been [__] uh I can't complain I'm
talking to the writer hopefully
Wednesday get that party started that's
really awesome and
uh you know I do the podcast with you
boom I'm
good laughing gas keeps me in [__]
potato chips is smoking the best reefer
out there they sent me these Edibles I
didn't bring them in with me oh my God
these tremendous Edibles they come in
different flavors and [__] the dad took
like three of them not knowing I didn't
know they were 175
milligrams oh [__] I took four of them
because they taste really [__] good
and I took four of them and I was
talking to George and he goes bro I ate
a half of one I'm still [__] up and
I'm like I ate four of them and then
that night I remember I came home
yesterday and it was at one point that I
put ice on my leg and I sat down and was
watching something it wasn't football
though and last night before I went to
bed I went into my
whoop and I went went to log in that I
was going to sleep and it logged in a
nap for 40 minutes it was when I had the
ice in my [__] foot because the
Edibles took me somewhere like they just
they they took you so fast you know what
I'm saying like they went and then it
just dropped me into a
[__] I've been there a couple times
what like is it a a gummy is it a
chocolate what is it
gummies a piece I'll save you some you
know what I'm saying we'll [__] we'll
mix them with the
ABX well I need them because I went I
went to go get some tonight but I I went
and got my uh my medical license here in
mass today after
work it was one of the craziest I can't
believe I forgot to tell you but this
dude was very nice he was like a 70
something 80y old doctor and he was
giving me like a history lesson on
marijuana but not the hard one but like
the medium one he said the nword
twice like
he like not the hard one but like the
one that's still not great he was
telling me the history about it and
saying like like the doctors just like
the whoever that guy was Reefer Madness
they said the the black people uh were
the only ones who smoked it and then he
just dropped that word
twice and I was like had to sit there
because I wanted my medical license but
I didn't know what to do I just didn't
I just keep nodding just yesing the that
you're right yeah good you're right oh I
haven't seen reefa Madness since I was
like [__]
14 no no you gotta be like 13 with a
propeller on your head to watch that
nonsense it's like black and white you
know it's got its moments but no it's
nobody's Academy Award winner by far and
I I just missed the doctors in LA like I
went to one on
Ventura I spent more time in the waiting
room than I did with the doctor the
doctor took three seconds oh yeah he
takes your blood pressure he makes
believe he gives a [__] you know this
guy 20 minutes on tpin yeah no it was
great La the first time I got my license
was like 30 minutes he talks to you you
know he's trying to cover the spread
he's asking you for the small
200 he's asking it for the small 200 the
first license I got was the small 200
and then the next time I reup it was
like
$99 [__] then it was $49 all day long
then it was $29 with a free hat
yeah and now you don't have to go
anywhere you can do it on your
phone I guess yeah that's how I did it
me I mind my [__] business I don't
know nothing my friend goes to La he
comes back he drops a little [__]
handkerchief off it's got a couple buds
in it and I live happily you know month
a month
absolutely I'm not going off the rails
I'm not smoking blunts I do the freeze
pipe you know three times a day
morning late
afternoon and 10:30 nappy Noo-noo
time that's not bad no that's not bad
and the Edibles that's why I can't
believe I ate them tonight I'm not I'm
on I'm in there I think I got to do some
things I'm in there but I'm not locked
in locked in locked in you know you know
how we do it play Oh I can tell no no no
you're doing hey you're doing a lot
better than most people at a th000
milligrams yeah a thousand plus because
I ate the chocolate bar 2500 bar I ate
the one for so it's got like maybe four
things I ate it's four it's 16 pieces
remember we did the math already it's
like uh 60 right milligrams a piece I
ate four that's another 240 you know who
you think you're dealing with some
[__] noice here I'm doing a [__]
checkin I gotta be Tip Top the goo I
don't show up like other people [__] no
you couldn't find Edibles you don't know
what happened the doctor you know they
only sell tens over there that's that's
why I had to get my license because they
only sell fives five so you ate 20 of
them I had well no I had last week
that's why I was I last week I finished
up the ABX you gave me um you don't
[__] tell me Well CU then you said I
got to you know I'm so I'm trying to I
had 10 tonight I had 50 but yeah I 10
gummies that's great that's
great you could be e [__] fentin all
light and [__] you don't know what fent
what is oh my God what
light
oh that's they give they give you fentol
[__] full you know what I'm saying
they got fentol light fentol medium and
fentol Nappy
n yeah Jesus Christ so be careful Su I'm
doing my best all right what you what
performances do you have this week this
week I have uh Wednesday night at um off
the rails in Worster and then th
Thursday through Saturday I'm at the
Kansas City improv with Josh Wolf oh
[__] yeah I'm so excited it's great
that's a great Club I think the lady is
still there that runs it oh that'd be
great send them my love she's good
people there was a dude there named
Kevin that's good people you
know crazy remember what's that that's
crazy that you remember all these names
you have to man you know after a while
you you it's so weird when you start to
travel and
then you think of these people what once
you're to a club like the second or
third time you saw it with me when we go
to Irvine we became friends with the
weight staff and then you go and the
weight staff will be gone and be
somebody else there and then one day you
go to Tempe and that weight staff that
you don't see anymore is the Tempe
Emperor and you don't even know where
you are whether you're in Irvine or Brea
it's crazy you become friends with them
and then you picture them as you're
flying in by the plane is landing you're
like oh I remember her I remember him
now oh [__] all right they text you
before you land we'll be at the airport
and you go oh now I remember her oh [__]
this place has the pork chops oh [__]
the waitress sells weed and now it all
becomes uh it comes in full [__]
Focus that's pretty awesome and it's
um I'm I'm excited about go this is one
like I've heard really cool things about
it I've never been to Kansas City
I'm just happy to go I'm really just
happy to go and do real shows at like
awesome clubs he's got a he's got
mushrooms that look like my fungi
toenail on the right you saw those too I
saw them they're like government issue
oh my God that late night Friday yeah
they for people come back from the war
when they're a little wobbly they give
them those high level
ones they look like baseball bats yeah
you're gonna hear you're not g to hear
stuff
I read up on those things you're not
going to hear your hearing is going to
leave because that's what it does it
stops you from hearing bombs oh wait I'm
not gonna hear noises but I'm just gonna
be I'm gonna be deaf for a little while
you know you're just gonna hear like a
little beep and you you're like somebody
shot a gun next to you oh you're gonna
be all that's good oh I'm really excited
you're tougher thans kid I can't believe
you're still out there pounding the
[__] pavement like an animal I'm
proud of you that's all that matters and
all you young Comics that are watching
this this is just a lesson man we're
just too [__] comedians talking about
[__] uh the road and menus and what's
next and I'm proud of Lee for getting
into this club hopefully they'll give
him some love or as much as they can
give him it's a small club and you know
it's a big area a lot of comics
everywhere you know any area you move
into now it's you're going to be around
a lot of comics and everybody has the
same story everybody brings their own
feature act so that's where you have to
decide what you want to do take a week
as an MC and get better as an MC and
meet another headline and the feature
act that you'll be friends with down the
road or where your ego takes you I'm a
headliner I'm never MC and then you
decide from
there I I I will MC for anybody I will
me too I'll still MC for anybody if I MC
you know what I'm saying maybe I could
MC
virtually you could no not get the [__]
off I not I know you're not going to but
oh no no no if I am but when I was
working I always MC even when I was
trying to be a really good feature act
if Josh Wolf got a weak featuring I
would go with him and [__] do guest
sets for free as long as I can sleep on
the floor with a [__] blanket I'm
good you know what I'm saying I was that
type of dude I always knew that a set
would make me that much stronger some
people would go I'm not doing a guess
set there [__] that guy you don't have
to like him but if you get a guess out
of the guy and work a joke that's more
than whatever personal feelings you have
for the guy at one point in comedy for
you to move forward you got to drop your
[__] personal feelings you know and
just attack that [__] like a set
you have a goal every year you got to
hit 300 something [__] sets and
you're here telling me you don't get
along with the guy you don't like him
because he busted your balls once you
know how you bust his balls go in there
and rock that [__] room go in there
and unhinge the [__] doors and then
walk past him and go follow that
[__] sorry about that I got emotion
when I talk about that type of
[__] do you and then like that's your
advice that's crazy that's my advice I
told you man one of the biggest lessons
I learned there was a Booker in Seattle
God Rest her soul a point somewhere
where she just didn't like me and she
told a friend of mine I'm not going to
book him anymore okay I took that but
she had 20,000 rooms and I couldn't take
that answer so I I knew she didn't like
me for a reason that had nothing to do
with stand up and I called her every
Wednesday I said' do you mind if I go to
this room and do a guess set what are
you going to say she would go yep and
she would be
angry and I knew it burned her up and I
would go every once a week I did one of
her rooms for free even the club Owners
would go how come we haven't seen you
and I would never badm her I I don't
know she she just she's just starting to
book me now hopefully you'll give him a
good report I knew I would never be back
at that club but it didn't matter I was
getting better I got there was a it was
it was like a a four Monon run where I
just did one of her rooms once a week to
burn her because because she didn't like
me for something
specific that had nothing to do with our
comedy and I had to be she didn't want
to pay me fine don't pay me but I'm
still going in there do a [__]
guess
set and then I that's it's just
interesting how to deal with like with
people who might not like you because
yeah I I get not nervous about it but I
guess kind of nervous about like that's
why I think I was so stuck on a specific
set that I just wanted to do well like I
just I get you get so in your head with
this stuff do I don't care who I was
showcasing for or what I'm
doing I'm getting the set out of this
[__] so even if I got a set that
I'm afraid to get away from that's I
understand that I want you to try
something new in the
middle because if you have that much
confidence in your set you're gonna have
if you it's A8 minute set I want you to
slip it in at the four minute Mark after
you're already
likable feel how the joke feels because
you probably tried an open mic and
there's eight people but now you're
going to try it in front of an audience
that likes you there's more than 30
people in there and then if the joke
goes forward there you go mental note if
it doesn't you got your four minutes to
close up with that you have so much
confidence in right always want you to
get something out of the [__] set
always take something from that set
you're bombing that's why you turn on
the Improv for a second make sure that
improv works and don't get
angry interesting if you open up that
field don't get angry if the guy CL is
you but some's funnier than you if
you're there for 20 minutes and you're
up at 10 you're in a bar and you're
doing 20 minutes and you have 10 Mark
they're giggling they're starting to say
[__] and you get into a heckling mark
with him no not that he's funny I don't
want you to let the comedy turn into a
temper and for you to say something
wrong and now you turn the audience on
you for sure and that's a mistake a lot
of young Comics make well [__] you man
I'm never coming to this dump
again wrong
answer you didn't have him from the
beginning don't let your ego get in
front of you you didn't have him from
the beginning you're trying to bail
yourself out and now at the end you dump
on the place or you dump on the host or
you dump on any other comedian or [__]
you you laughed at the guy with the
organ you just blew your [__] whole
night I want you to absolutely go out
there and leave there on your feet it's
over okay to have a bad
set that's what's great about
tomorrow or what's great about that
[__] bowling Alle that does comedy at
midnight that you don't like to go to
because everybody's drunk well you ate
such a bag of dicks here you might as
well go down there and earn your [__]
stripe tonight there's always an answer
to a bomb do not be scared to bomb
please once you take that safety that
off your comedy career goes 80% % High
don't be scared to bomb the common
mistake of young comedians in and I did
it for years once once you were losing
him was to panic never Panic take a step
back and go back to basics goof on
yourself W this ain't working I guess I
gotta stop [__] doing heroin now and
just take them until something else
comes to your mind don't let them see
you sweat
correct I I've never thought about it
like but it makes sense it it it it
explains why some sets have gone bad bad
for me absolutely you got at one point
in your career the five six year level
it's time to take the safety and and off
it's time to work differently it's time
to go up there to
bomb you went up there to bomb yeah go
up there to bomb I want you to go up
there and see how it is to really bomb
you already established yourself now go
up there and see what it's really like
to bomb how you guys doing tonight
look at you where' you coming from
Buffalo oh your wings are tired just go
up there and see the real feeling of a
bomb and get off and giggle about it and
you'll go wow that's what it feels like
the bomb that ain't that bad I'd rather
do that than go up and rely on my
material for 10 years because I'm scared
to take a [__]
chance holy [__] that that freaks me out
so much like have you heard of people
say um an intrusive
thought you have you heard people talk
about that it's like when you're driving
over a bridge and some people like oh
maybe I should drive off a bridge I've
thought before going on stage sometimes
and when like I'm freaking out that
maybe I should just say like just really
eat [__] on purpose just because it's
gonna go by bad anyways but like I don't
want you to eat [__] on purpose but I
also when you go to these open mics I
want you to go up there to bomb why we
want so long oh my God it's giving me
anxiety you know what it's like it's
like you being a fighter and training
and before the fight I take you aside
and go Lee we got a problem
today we got a problem you gotta go down
the third round oh down the fourth round
and the third you got to take one for
the team you know we got you back we got
ourselves into a
situation yeah but at least hopefully in
that case like maybe you only take one
punch to the face you're not bombing on
purpose for 10 minutes I'm other guy and
tell him to punch you in the stomach
until you bleed out your ears just to
have fun you know what I'm saying oh
Jesus you know what I'm saying I mean no
but like I can't imagine going up there
to bomb on purpose Lee that's why it's
so interesting how I turned the bomb
away from you guys young Comics medium
Comics this is how I didn't give a [__]
when I lived in Seattle at the six and
seven year
mark there were nights I went up there
to a bomb and I bail myself out i' put
myself in a hole and then I take myself
out of the ho that takes a couple
weeks let's have some fun in your career
Co suckers that takes a couple weeks and
then you learn how to maintain at the
like you know before they say boo how to
before tomato comes up and you got to
use your dodging skills now you got to
learn how to work them back in look at
you [__] got a little you don't
know who you're dealing with ba just
start talking get them excited and then
you hit them and boom you win them
over and then now you're like see you
[__] thought I was some [__]
bum from across the street I was just
trying [__] on you and you explain your
point and you you goof again on them and
then you get the [__] out of
there Joey bananas you think you got
some [__] novice here I never even
thought about that you would build bad
jokes into your set so that the good
jokes would be like would like hit
harder that's [__] like Evil Genius
like like come on come
on I love all have bad jokes in here on
purpose yeah you want to talk chicken
I'll talk chicken with you
[__] you you know dog I took a
lot of when I go to these rooms that
didn't matter i' still respect the
comedy
but I go off the deep end a little bit
how do you think I got that confidence
to do that in the comedy store because I
never did it before because no that's
what you need that's what's going to
sell you your character we're going back
to just be
yourself so tonight you look on the
paper and write out the best version of
yourself would you how would you tell me
to suck your [__] I want you to write it
20 different ways I want you to write it
angry and I want you to write it funny
that we're going to laugh at it this is
the music of words and this is where you
start to learn
tone and what do you mean by
Tone how to use your voice like volume
volumes heavy went to steamroll them
went to P back a little
bit just throw some Jabs at
them and like how many like like let's
say for example because I now I'm just
building it let's say you had this joke
and you could either pull back or
steamroll them and like how would you do
each would you do it three times each
four times like how would you decide
which one was the
best to see where they
go listen once you cemented the joke for
a weekend once you took the joke to
Kansas City for a weekend and you
[__] cemented the
joke now it's got to go somewhere now
you got to start adding things to
that and now that's where the beauty
really starts anybody could write the
joke like me I could always write the
joke but I really couldn't add that much
Beauty to it so I had to turn it into
storytelling we'll get to that some
other [__] podcast right now just
learn how to bomb
gracefully that's the most important
[__]
thing you've already felt what a good
set feels like right now you got to feel
what a a [__] bad set looks like what
a bad set feels like and know this that
you'll never you'll learn how to never
feel that way by learning how to control
your
sets
I don't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
where you start it's where you
finish and it's not a [__] race it's
a
marathon some of the best Comics I've
ever seen are Comics that could hold
your
attention and and talk and just
gracefully go into a joke anybody could
machine gun you like me anybody could
tell a story there's guys that are real
Craftsman we'll get to those later good
luck this week with your sets
[__] than I love you guys stick
around I got to talk to you about
manscape it's time to shave your ball
[Music]
sack the checkin is brought to you by
manscape it's time to look nice even if
you've been naughty manscape make sure
your grooming is in check with a fres
fresh launch just in time for the
holiday season their new performance
package
5.0 the L M more 5.0 Ultra body trimmer
the weed whacker 2.0 and the ear and
nose hair trimmer their crop suda
aftershave lotion which is tremendous by
the way and their crop preserver ball
deodorant that attracts them like a
[__] listen I love this new [__]
lone mower it's stronger than ever this
[__] thing my white hairs they just
fly off now it's tremendous and the weed
whacker for the
ear Cuts right through everything wax
staming juice your nose hairs thank God
there's no Coke in that nose no more
this thing would cut right through those
cup little cut things like Nino in New
Jack
City anyway the Lum more 5.0 Ultra does
all the heavy lifting with with two Next
Generation blade heads it's even
waterproof so you can knock it out of
your shaving routine while you shower
who's better than you manscape get 20%
off in free shipping right now this
holiday season with code Joey Joe y
manscape.com That's 20% off with free
shipping at manscape.com
use code Joey Joe y listen there's the
perfect grip for Grandpa don't let him
his hairs are longer than de he's been
praying at home who's going to cut my
little knuckle my little Stam Roots here
nobody the checkin is also brought to
you by stamps.com listen if you're a
business owner like your Uncle Joey and
you have a sleigh to help you with
deliveries this Christmas you need
stamps.com stamps.com is your own
personal post office wherever you are
all you need is a computer and a printer
that's it print your own postage at
discounts up to 84% off of us PS and UPS
rates and stance.com will even let you
know the cheapest and fastest shipping
options to help you save even
more I'm back if you want to save time
as well as money you can even schedule
package pickups through the stamps.com
dashboard it couldn't be any easier so
do me a favor give your business the
gift of stamps.com so your mailing and
shipping is covered this holiday season
I don't care how small or big your
business is stamps.com is the way to go
sign up with promo code Joey for a
special offer that includes a 4-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale no long-term commitment to
contracts just go to stance.com Click
the microphone at the top of the page
and Preston Co joeey